quand on évoque la nationale 7 on pense
tout de suite à vacances soleil platane
c'est vraiment les trois images qui
viennent à l'esprit les incendies alors
que l'ouest de la france a connu une
journée historiquement chaude les
records de températures ont été battus
un peu partout notamment en bretagne et
la nuit salon suffocante la fumée semble
jaillir du cratère d'un volcan
nous sommes pourtant bien au dessus de
la dune du pilat le feu progresse de
minute en minute dans sa direction
dévore hectares après tard la forêt qui
l'entourent y en a pas de réaction la
fabrication
est ce que tu sais pas forcément mais
alors je ne sais pas je sais pas j'ai un
restaurant mais je sais pas
moi je dis qu'est ce que tu fous dans le
resto si tu sais pas mais ça vous
inquiète quant au t1 bruno quand on
annonce qu'on va vite peut-être la
journée la plus chaude de météorologie
qui croyaient pas au réchauffement
climatique c'est
un bizutage tu m'as 10h30 and george
hill pas dissuadé le changement
climatique tout ça c'est n'importe quoi
on ne mord pas leur dire tu vas aller
voir les gens qui tuent le risque y est
eh ouais et paf responsabilités c'est
toi le patron
sa troupe a choisi alors
j
assume on va dire je ne suis pas là la
csn échec total riche et d'acier de la
cena federico là on est désolé
très clairement ces événements qu'on
considérait avant comme des événements
exceptionnels vont devenir la norme
c'est un des effets du changement
climatique ça va être d'augmenter
l'intensité et la fréquence de ces
phénomènes exceptionnels là je suis je
fais un peu le tour des médias sur la
question de la vague de chaleur l'été
dernier c'était les inondations et donc
malheureusement il va falloir s'adapter
à ce qui devient la nouvelle normalité
veut dire quoi s'adapter alors comme
dirait johnny noir c'est noir y a plus
d'espoir
[Musique]
on essaie de se rapprocher de la
perfection
déjà menotté la jeune fille ne supporte
pas d'être attaché par la ceinture de
sécurité
on vous colle mais on n'est pas beaucoup
par
racontez nous un peu qu'est ce que vous
faites pour les pompiers mais écoutez
ici comme tous les bénévoles nous sommes
heureusement un problème de son pour
traverser la place de la mairie bonjour
monsieur tout le monde accélère tout de
suite ont envie d'aller à londres en
effet avec le soleil
oui bah en fait pas je pas dit oui comme
vous avez pu voir en tout cas le nombre
de personnes dans le monde qui est
directement exposé à la hosi ou des
mères continuent augmenté alors qu'il
devrait décroître pourquoi s'ils
continuent à augmenter parce qu'on
continue à construire en bordure de
littoral dans des sous les 38 ans d'eads
enfin tout de rendre voulait pas vendre
up non pas de vous tenir et on trouvera
jamais si bien qu ici au caire doit pas
recevoir mais là c'est la mort ben oui
autant contourna il ya tout de suite non
jamais alors regardez ce que fait le
gouvernement indonésien ils sont en
train de déplacer leur capitale djakarta
de l'île de java vers l'iss bornéo parce
qu'ils savent très bien que dans trente
ans jacques atteint 5,6 au fait lors de
l'apéro
faisons nôtre cousinade donc du coup on
a décidé de venir faire le dessin elle
après le pique nique il est certain que
des canicules vont être de plus en plus
intense et par conséquent 50 degrés ça
arrivera pas d'ici 2030 mais
effectivement au cours du siècle au
cours des prochaines décennies il y a un
vrai risque que cela arrive en france
les habitants s'y attendait ils se sont
adaptés
de l'autre côté de la rue elle fait bien
chaud je vais choisir le côté ombre et
je suis pourtant de marché de ce côté là
il va accepter de se dévêtir c'est plus
difficile c'est que quand il fait très
chaud quand il fait très froid en moi
qui compte
leur foi j'approuve sur la cité une
évidence s'est imposée
[Musique]
ça c'est le cadeau chez soleil levé
l'immunité ça fait partie des miracles
ce voyage à pied
c'est ce qu'on appelle un ciel enflammé
[Musique]